-Performing "Thérèse"
from her album "Moss,"
please welcome Maya Hawke!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Oh, my God,
I gotta slow it down now ♪
♪ Oh, my God,
I gotta slow it down somehow ♪
I gotta slow it down now ♪
♪ Oh, my God,
I gotta slow it down somehow ♪
♪ Down somehow, down somehow ♪
♪ Oh, my God,
I gotta slow down ♪
♪ Mmmmmmm ♪
♪♪
♪ I go see Thérèse dreaming ♪
♪ She's stretching out
her sore shoulder ♪
♪ Leaning back, eyes closed,
reaching up ♪
♪ She's wishing she was older ♪
♪ Dreaming of an Appaloosa
saddled up ♪
♪ Riding out of town ♪
♪ Dreaming of a Shelby Cobra ♪
♪ Digging her tires
in the ground ♪
♪ Bleeding, bringing in
a new year's mess ♪
♪ Unaware of the stain
on her dress ♪
♪ It's tactless, it's a test ♪
♪ It's just Thérèse,
it's just Thérèse ♪
♪ White kitten in the corner ♪
♪ Obscene,
it really says it all ♪
♪ Milk matches her underwear ♪
♪ Get her down,
take her off the wall ♪
♪ She dreams of Marlon
in Austin ♪
♪ Their bodies tangled
in a net ♪
♪ She thinks of him
every so often ♪
♪ When she feels like
a space cadet ♪
♪ She empathizes
with your feelings ♪
♪ She's more interested
in ceilings ♪
♪ It's tactless, it's a test ♪
♪ It's just Thérèse,
it's just Thérèse ♪
♪ It's tactless, it's a test ♪
♪ It's just Thérèse,
it's just Thérèse ♪
♪♪
♪ She reminds me of memories ♪
♪ Sleeping off
the growing pains ♪
♪ We were sea anemones ♪
♪ Spelling out
each other's names ♪
♪ Whispering
inside our red house ♪
♪ While the adults
were asleeping ♪
♪ I guess Thérèse
was just for me ♪
♪ A quiet I keep on keeping ♪
♪ Thérèse does not
belong to you ♪
♪ The horses, cars,
and cowboys do ♪
♪ It's tactless, it's a test ♪
♪ It's just Thérèse,
it's just Thérèse ♪
♪ It's tactless, it's a test ♪
♪ It's just Thérèse,
it's just Thérèse ♪
♪ It's tactless, it's a test ♪
♪ It's just Thérèse,
it's just Thérèse ♪
♪ It's tactless, it's a test ♪
♪ It's just Thérèse ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]